hello welcome to reality check
do not attempt to adjust your computer
this week's episode focuses on some
highly sensitive information so for your
safety I've decided to conceal my own
identity so no one can possibly work
here we are come on cam that works a
weekly show remember you're literally
the only hope why Craig need to
concentrate while i hack into the CT us
to find out how close the hyper surveyed
world of watchdogs is to real life
oh god break we're being backed out
okay so clearly I'm rubbish at hacking
so let's put this question to a couple
of experts instead enter Chris Boyd
Angie Abbot Chris aka paper ghost is a
computer security researcher and malware
intelligence analyst for malwarebytes
and jay is the managing director of
advanced security consulting limited and
chair of the UK's cybersecurity
challenge so chaps how close exactly is
the hyper surveillance filled world of
watchdogs to real-life society in terms
of surveillance it's definitely becoming
more and more of an issue for a lot of
people I mean even on the way into the
studio today I played the game of count
the CCTV cameras and I gave up a 50 and
that's just between here in the train
station and the UK couldn't Lee has I
think about four to six million cameras
across the country were watchdogs is set
in Chicago Chicago is is I believe one
of the most heavily surveilled cities in
the world
and there are no so many government
agencies and private agencies that have
all of this data the governments
themselves don't actually know quite
where it's gone who's got a lot of
people don't realize but some cameras in
central locations actually have audio
feeds as well as video feeds so they can
hear what's being said whoever
everyone's watching them at any one time
is a different question but the
connectivity exists and they certainly
have the ability to share data and share
a sort of information flowing between
environments CTOs this is the key in
watchdogs to Chicago's hi-tech
infrastructure and surveillance through
it anyone with access can trigger
traffic lights security cameras trains
even bridges and as a result all of this
infrastructure can be controlled by main
character Aiden Pearce thanks to his
hacking skills but is there an analogue
for this centralized system in real life
there are a lot of important systems out
there the control everything from you
know the banking sector to industrial
systems power plants but in real life if
all these systems were as interconnected
as their it would be a complete disaster
you would have things going wrong you
would have people wandering into systems
that they're not supposed to be in so
the connectivity exists to make it all
centralized but not every city or not
every country has centralized their
environments so it is still possible
technically to access all of these
systems individually but there's not
kind of one one door you can walk
through and you've got the keys to the
kingdom
Eden's tool of choice for hacking
shenanigans isn't a beefy rig with a
hardwired fiber optic connection oh no
all he needs is his smartphone so can I
really hack a computer or a city or even
hack the planet with just this the
reality is is that you know the phone in
your pocket is as much a computer as the
one on your desk the old Nokia n900 is
the phone of choice because it's such a
good platform anything Android based you
can load an operating system onto and
you literally do have the same toolkit
you would have on your laptop or on your
PC at home in your pocket that you can
use anywhere so let's assume for one
second and then we'll make a big leap of
faith here that you know the core
critical infrastructure that you want to
accesses is on a wireless connection
which is unlikely I might add then at
that point you've just got to interface
with it in some way so you've got to
essentially query it ask it questions or
see how it answers and by confusing them
or asking them to do something slightly
different to what they were expecting
you can elicit responses which you can
never manipulate and manipulating those
responses is ultimately all hacking it
now you've got to remember so this is a
traffic light system or say this is a
you know the drawbridge well it's going
to be entirely proprietary it's not
going to be like
hello drawbridge would you like to raise
now it's gonna be an entirely new and to
you completely random set of characters
you can never seen before because once
you've actually gained access to a
system you've got to figure out how it
works so you've got to become an
administrative level knowledge user of
that system with no training
tricky stuff but what if we lower our
hacking aspirations just a little once
again using just his humble smartphone
Hayden can quite easily snoop on all his
fellow citizens with just the push of a
button hacking into their personal data
now say why to use this phone to do the
very same to find out lots of sordid
details of our cameraman Greg for
example yeah what there's so many public
facing databases that people are on and
don't necessarily know how to opt-out of
all you need is say someone's real name
off Twitter and you can go off if you've
got a general idea reading through their
tweets where they're located where they
went to the shops where they went out
for a meal you can bring up directory
inquiries or the electoral roll there's
a good chance they probably have an
opted out and within minutes you've got
their full name you've got their address
you've probably got an age band
you've probably got information on their
relatives that live with them how long
they've been there for and it's really
up to what you're trying to achieve with
that information but it's you know it's
all out there but you know what
aaden's knows the activities don't stop
there he's also able to interface it
with the phones of surrounding
bystanders and read their personal
messages and emails so is this possible
with the right smartphone and know-how
if you can create a portable hotspot
that that phone automatically connects
to which is actually very rudimentary to
do then you have instantly created a
situation where that phone trusts you
and it will start interfacing through
you to gain access to services that it
uses normally so at that point so for
instance that phone will try and check
its email well it's going to pass that
username and password through your phone
so technically if you've got the right
setup you can intercept that information
and then log in to their email account
and read their email so that's actually
very very very simple to do it is
remarkably simple to do most people
don't understand that
but what about using all this hacking
for something actually useful
wait device are useful I meant highly
illegal money is no object to aiden
pearce so you can quite happily hacked
funds from other people's bank accounts
and then transfer into his own please
tell me this isn't a real thing yeah I
mean thankfully it's it's actually quite
difficult to hack into someone's online
banking account if you know if you if I
was walking down the street you don't
need some online banking it's it's a
secure connection if the sites probably
gonna make me jump through an awful lot
of Hoops to login they'll be passwords
with these security codes so generally
people will try and use social
engineering or phishing the emails where
they send you a link to a fake website
and still it's still your login that way
that's that's still a lot more
straightforward and a lot more common
thankfully than just walking past
someone in the street oh my money's gone
well like it or not it seems that our
modern world is not that dissimilar from
the one in watchdogs but what do you
think about all this does it worry you
that we live in such a hyper-connected
information-rich society or perhaps you
think the benefits of all this
definitely outweigh the risks let me
know in the comments down below or by
sending me a tweet at cam for us Rob
last week on reality check I explored
the rather vague question of what is the
biggest game in the world YouTube
comments are big Martin 58 pitched them
with real-life racked up approximately a
hundred and seventy three thousand hours
of gameplay so far and I'd say it still
got a good 700 thousand dollars left now
for my quick calculations I can see that
big Martin 58 is hoping to live to just
shine one hundred and gfriend I say good
luck oh just one last thing I want to
take this opportunity to pay tribute to
and say a huge thank you to cameraman
Greg who is very sadly leaving us at the
end of this week he's after pastures new
and exciting so good luck in the future
Greg and see you guys next week